>> IT'S TIME FOR OUR SEEN AND
UNSEEN SEGMENT WHEN WE REVEAL
THE STORIES BEHIND THE HEADLINE
AND FOR THAT WE TURN TO RAYMOND
ARROYO CARRIED YOU ARE JUST AT
THE BORDER A FEW WEEKS AGO, AND
NOW THERE ARE REPORTS THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS POISED
TO MAKE THE BORDER CRISIS EVEN
WORSE?
WHAT?
>> AS YOU SAW WHEN I WAS AT THE
RIO GRANDE, WITNESSING HUNDREDS
OF MIGRANTS BEING BROUGHT,
STATESIDE BY THE CARTELS, AGENT
TOLD ME THEY HAD ONE GREAT FEAR
THAT THE BIDEN MINISTRATION
WOULD LIFT TITLE 42.
THIS IS THE PUBLIC HEALTH LAW
THAT DUE TO COVID ALLOWED BORDE
PATROL TO TURN BACK THOUSANDS O
SINGLE ADULTS TRYING TO ENTER
THE UNITED STATES.
AXIOMS IS REPORTING THAT BIDEN
COULD REMOVE TITLE 42 BY THE EN
OF JULY.
WITHOUT THIS LONG PLACE,
OFFICIALS TOLD ME TODAY THAT
THEY ARE GOING TO BE OVERWHELMED
.
THEY WILL HAVE TO RELEASE MORE
THAN 100,000 ILLEGAL ALIENS EAC
MONTH POTENTIALLY.
WHAT ABOUT THE COVID
CONSIDERATIONS, WE WANT TO
VACCINATE STUDENTS AND SPORT
STARS, WHAT ABOUT MIGRANTS?
THE GATE THEY WILL GET FREE
VACCINES ANYWAY.
WE HAVE SO MUCH EXTRA CASH.
STILL RESTRICTIONS IN PLACE.
ACROSS THE BORDER ILLEGALLY, BU
THE MIGRANTS CAN JUST POUR RIGH
IN.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
WE CLOSE THE BORDER TO LEGAL
MEXICANS, AND CANADIANS, BUT
HUNDREDS OF THOUSAND, A MILLION
ALMOST HAVE COME ACROSS FRED.
>> AGENTS TOLD ME TODAY OF THE
180 ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS THAT THE
ENCOUNTERED 180,000, THEY TURNE
BACK 112,000 BECAUSE OF THIS
TITLE 42.
WITH THAT OUT THE WINDOW, IT'S
OPEN SEASON AND AMERICA BECOMES
THE SEASON.
LAURA, SOME ARE INDIGNANT AND
DOWNRIGHT SILLY IN THEIR
COVERAGE OF THE CATHOLIC BISHOP
EFFORTS TO REMIND THEIR FLOCK O
THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES IN PUBLIC
.
BISHOPS ARE DRAFTING A DOCUMENT
TO RECEIVE COMMUNION.
BASICALLY, THE STANDARDS OF
MEMBERSHIP.
HERE IS HOW THE MEDIA IS
COVERING IT.
>> CATHOLIC BISHOPS HERE IN
AMERICA PUSHING TO ALLOW PRIEST
TO DENY THE PRESIDENT COMMUNION
OVER HIS SUPPORT OF ABORTION
RIGHTS FRED.
>> THE PRESIDENT MADE CLEAR HE
IS NOT PLANNING TO CHANGE HIS
ROUTINE IN THE FACE OF THE
CATHOLIC BISHOPS.
>> THIS IS SO MISINFORMED I
DON'T KNOW WHERE TO BEGIN.
THIS BISHOPS DOCUMENT MEANS
NOTHING.
CANON LAW, CHURCH LAW REQUIRES
PRIESTS AND BISHOPS TO REFUSE
COMMUNION TO ANYONE WHO PERSIST
IN MANIFESTS PUBLIC, GRAVESEND.
IT'S NOT AN OPTION.
THE PROBLEM IS THE LOCAL BISHOP
RESPONSIBLE, THEY REFUSE TO ASK.
BIDEN IS ONLY ONE OF MANY
CATHOLIC FIGURES OPPOSING CORE
MORAL TEACHING IN PUBLIC.
THIS ISN'T PRIVATE SIN, IT'S
PUBLIC SIN AND THEY ARE TEACHIN
OTHER CATHOLICS OUT TO BEHAVE.
NOW THAT THE BISHOPS ARE HAVING
A DISCUSSION, MADE MEDIA
COMMENTATORS ARE BESIDE
THEMSELVES.
>> FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN WHO IN
THAT MOVEMENT IS JUST JOE BIDEN
GOING TWO HIS CHURCH AND TAKING
THAT MOMENT TO HONOR HIS BELIEFS
, THAT SHOULD NOT BE
WEAPON EYES AGAINST HIM.
>> THESE BISHOPS COULD BE
WORKING WITH HIM FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE.
AND ON THE REFUGEE CRISIS AND
WHAT HAVE YOU, AND POVERTY IN
THIS COUNTRY,.
>> PEOPLE JUST SEE IT AS REALLY
JUST HYPOCRISY.
SOME PEOPLE SAID THIS IS THE
FINAL STRAW FOR THEM, IF THE
BISHOPS GO AHEAD WITH THAT,
THAT'S IT FOR THEM.
>> WAIT A SECOND.
IS THAT A PRIEST?
WAS THAT THE PRIEST?
YES, FATHER BACK HE NEEDS A
REFRESHER IN THE CATECHISM.
IF TRUTH IN ADVERTISING AND
INSISTING THAT CATHOLICS BEHAVE
LIKE CATHOLICS IN PUBLIC IS A
BAD THING, THEN THEY BETTER GO
FIND ANOTHER FAITH.
NO ONE IS.
IF YOU SEE ONE THING, THEN BE AT
.
>> JOY BEHAR IS IN TOWN.
LISTEN TO JOY.
>> BEFORE I GO, SENATOR SHELDON
WHITEHOUSE OF RHODE ISLAND, I
KNOW A FRIEND OF YOURS, WAS
CORNERED BY A LOCAL REPORTER
OVER HIS MEMBERSHIP IN THE
FEELIES BEACH CLUB, THIS IS AN
EXCLUSIVE VERY RESTRICTED RESOR
THAT HE HAS ENJOYED FOR DECADES.
>> ARE THERE ANY MINORITY
MEMBERS IN THE CLUB NOW?
>> AND THINK THE PEOPLE RUNNING
THE PLACE ARE STILL WORKING ON
THAT.
>> THE REMARKS ON THE FLOOR
FOLLOWING THE DEATH OF TAYLOR
AND GEORGE FLOYD SAY HOPING TO
SYSTEMIC RACISM IN THE COUNTRY.
YOUR TAKE ON THE WEALTHY CLUB I
THIS GAME AGED, SHOULD THESE
CLUBS CONTINUE TO EXIST?
>> IT'S A LONG TRADITION IN
RHODE ISLAND AND THERE ARE MANY
OF THEM.
>> PLAN MEETINGS ARE TRADITIONS
IN SOME PARTS OF THE COUNTRY TO
COME ALORA.
THIS IS OVER THE LINE.
THEY CLAIMED THE CLUB DOES HAVE
DIVERSE MEMBERSHIP AND THAT HE
WILL NO LONGER BE A MEMBER, BUT
REMEMBER, HIS WIFE IS THE THIRD
LARGES